flip-flop star Kristina al Musa steps
out for the first time since announcing
she and husband Trek are separating
Christina was seen at a mall in Yorba
Linda California on Tuesday sporting
grey leggings a pullover sweater that
read pink champagne
can't complain she accessorized the all
grey ensemble with oversized Sony's and
a Louie Vuitton handbag and eye witness
tells et the HGTV star was subdued
keeping her sunglasses on in her head
down flipping houses is our passion
Tarek and Christina confirmed their
split on Monday after seven years of
marriage in a joint statement - et cetra
in part during the process we are
committed to our kids and being the best
parents we can be we will continue to
work through this process civilly and
cooperatively and plan to continue our
professional life together we're
constantly on the move this is what we
do but family always comes first since
the split Christina has been spending
time with their children six-year-old
daughter Taylor and one-year-old son
Brayden though the couple have parted
ways HGTV tells Ichi the popular
house-flipping series will continue
production as scheduled
you